we have this story from the post
millennial fourth indictment against
Trump expected in Georgia next week
Willis has stated that she plans to
announce potential charges by September
1st at the latest
I don't know what to tell you man
everything we see happening
what do you think is going to happen in
in 2024 you think there's going to be
it's going to be some peaceful everyone
comes and shakes hands and smiles with a
degree of psychotic behavior I mean they
just gunned a guy down and killed him in
his house yeah whether you're I'm not
making a comment on anything other than
that that a guy died
I we with the with the uh the level of
intensity that now I feel like it's a
kind of Calm before the storm kind of
thing because it has it has been really
chill like news wise when it comes to
the actual election and stuff there
there hasn't been any kind of big
developments to talk about uh I mean we
keep talking about you know this
DeSantis kind of just petering out
that's been the big story for days and
days and days or you know maybe Vivek is
is getting some traction stuff but it's
still it's mostly very chill you know
not not big announcements or anything
like that so I feel like you know
it is the Calm before the storm and it's
I feel like it's going to be really
really weird with AI and the way that
and the way that's all effects yeah
they've only just begun yeah and I think
that like I said now is the Calm before
the storm but I think that once once the
election starts or once the campaigning
starts getting in her going into Earnest
it's gonna be really weird with
people aren't going to know what to
believe you're not and it's going to be
really weird I don't know that I don't
know that anyone's ever gonna feel
confident about who won a an election
ever again just because they're gonna
feel like they I don't know that people
are gonna feel like they confidently
can say that they made an informed
decision that was actually informed by
the truth as opposed to you know really
propagandized so I think it's going to
be a mess whether Biden or Trump becomes
the next president and I don't think
we're on the verge of some like Civil
War I think people are too lazy for it
still honestly like you might have a few
people who are real amped up uh but I
mean the FBI has been murdering people
for a long time that's you know I
understand that this is politically
charged but everything every murder the
FBI has ever committed in the past has
been politically charged so I don't
think this is necessarily a new thing
and uh you know if you're not online all
the time you talk to people like they're
a little worried about stuff but not
nearly at the levels that everyone is on
Twitter and social media so I don't
think that we're at the verge of any
sort of conflict when people one of the
things that I think when people say that
is I think of the the idea that there's
only a certain small percentage of
people that are involved in any kind of
like political
whether it be you know activists or
whether it be you know you know
um just going out and demonstrating or
protesting or whether it be people that
actually do you know get violent and
stuff it's it's always a small minority
of people that that get into you know
get into that stuff like Tim's talked
multiple times about how when he was in
Egypt like you know there was a the Arab
Spring was like literally kicking off in
Egypt but at the same time there were
people that were like you know at cafes
just going about their normal day and I
feel like the people that are on Twitter
and stuff are most likely the people
that are going to be would be the ones
that would be at least the most likely
to be politically informed so it seems
to me to be to make sense that those
people would be the most likely to be
politically active well up to including
you know violence I think you nailed it
it's it's never the majority it it is
never it like
I I don't think there's there's a
there's for the most part a conflict in
history where the overwhelming majority
of a population was actively
participating in a conflict even in in
World War II we're looking at you know
what is like a million some odd uh
conscriptions in in in a country of at
the time what was it uh how many people
were around then it's a fraction yeah
it's a fraction I bet I bet at that then
maybe what like 60 to 100 million or
something like that probably less
what is it in 1941 uh yeah 132 million
132 million and how many how many
soldiers did we construct a million I
don't know is somewhere around there
yeah so that's like you know what 0.7
.00 small percentage that we're actively
engaged in the conflict and the reality
is the people were conscripted weren't
actual participants in the conflict in
the sen in the political sense it was
like I gotta tell you I bet most people
didn't care
and if you went around I bet there were
people going like yeah but if you ask if
you ask your neighbor they don't care
about Germany or what's going on yet
somehow we found ourselves in that
conflict so what I see happening you get
this guy he's posting on social media
saying this horrifying stuff you get
antifa you get violent extremists who go
out and the majority of people will
cower but conflict happens eventually
what happens is the question of who's in
charge there's that a moment met taibi
wrote about where two cars speed towards
the police station two men in suits jump
out run full speed up to the door run
inside and run to the police even say
arrest that man and point to each other
and now the police chief says uh which
one do I arrest who's in charge what
happens then there's a bunch of
different ways these things like this go
you have Revolution you have military
Takeover in Egypt the military took over
the military just decided you know what
the civil unrest is too much and they
removed the president twice in the span
of I think like a year but most people
aren't paying attention to that I look
outside and they're the guys sitting in
McDonald's watching soccer he doesn't
care I went to the mall in heliopolis
while the revolution is taking place in
Egypt and people were just shopping for
cell phones and if you asked any one of
them not a single person cared and then
a day later the military removed the
president who was duly elected why he
was he was a Muslim and the secular
people in the country there was there
were more secular people than Muslim
Brotherhood supporters but the Muslim
brother was the largest faction of
Voters so they won it was a legitimate
first pass the post-election military
said we don't care but the average
person out shopping
I go to a cafe I'm having coffee
nobody's talking about it now you
actually go out and you'll you'll hear
people talk about it so it's worrying to
me in that I don't expect the average
person to care I'm concerned about the
people who are politically active and
motivated and I'm concerned with look if
the reality is you're right nobody cares
and no one's gonna do anything then
we're dealing with a federal government
that has just Amplified their corruption
100 fold to the point where they're like
Watergate was a scandal this apparently
Joe Biden's still the good guy that is a
degree of corruption and malfeasance we
have never seen in this country before
and what nothing's happening yo this it
breaks down if nothing happens if we
don't have a new like the the best case
scenario for everybody
Trump or Vivek or or even Rhonda Santos
any one of these guys who pledge just to
fire people the best case scenarios they
do get elected they do fire people they
do start weeding out corruption and we
turn this ship upright and we start
saving it otherwise the two scenarios
are overt conflict between angry
political factions or
Revolution yeah what bothers psychotic
despots go around and mercilessly beat
arrest and lock up innocent people what
gets me about these faction conflicts is
that I think if there's an enemy of the
United States they would want that to
happen it's very easy to destroy or take
over or surpass an enemy if they're in
fighting if they're in the middle of a
half the country's fighting itself so
they want people to walk outside and be
like hold on there I think you're the
enemy and the other person's like no no
hold on there you're the enemy I saw it
on TV they're like no I saw it on TV
that's what they want so if people are
brainwashed or afraid or dommed then
they might do that but if so not only do
we need to weed out corruption within
the government itself we need to control
the media in a way or at least influence
the media so that people are not afraid
of each other maybe I think that's
that's naive I think when you have
people like these leftists who've come
on this show or the culture War who
directly advocate for giving children
sexual explicit content I don't know
what you're what you're arguing for you
tell those people I'm sorry I am not
going to allow you to present this book
of adult pictures to Children you should
be in prison and they argue I've got 80
million people at my back that tell you
to STFU now you've got a problem
um I'm I mean throwing people in prison
for advocating for a book is different I
didn't say anything about throwing them
in prison you just said you should be in
prison you just said that the forgiving
the pictures to Children these are the
people that came on this show no no I'm
saying the people who are giving these
books to kids should be in prison so the
80 million people at their back voting
in support of it and you ask them and
they'll deny it they'll say well I don't
know about that but they're certainly
complicit in it will you say the reason
I was just going to say I think the
federal government's a lost cause in
trying to Kumbaya everybody and uh peace
again is not going to happen so I think
that separation and people going to
places where people think the same way
they are is the ultimate solution I mean
at this point you know when I see
conservatives crying about the Streets
of San Francisco and like how horrible
it's become I'm just like I don't take
them seriously anymore it's like why do
you care about San Francisco anymore
it's so obviously toast and gone or
Chicago because they vote in our federal
elections which have an impact on
not protecting our borders whether or
not the government is increasing the tax
rate so when you have California
bringing in non-citizens and using that
to inflate their census numbers so they
get more votes in Congress and
intellectual College we've got a very
very serious problem with what San
Francisco is doing yeah well that's
that's the problem right there that they
have control over us and the solution is
trying to decrease the control that
these other states have over us the
federal government needs to decentralize
instead of trying to fix it and just get
better people into these positions we
need to go back to a more decentralized
approach like the 10th Amendment
actually provided for yeah but I don't I
don't completely agree with that I I
maybe would have agreed with it a while
ago but now we see the issue of these
west coast states
passing laws where people can kidnap
children and then sterilize them and the
state will protect the kidnapper
so there's a problem then when we say
everybody just pick your state and then
shut up okay what happens when you're in
Oklahoma
and uh is it is it Oklahoma let me make
sure I have my States right
what happens if you're in it might be
Kansas I gotta make sure I think I think
it's Oklahoma
what happens when hold on yeah adjacent
to Colorado yeah yeah that's the point I
was going to make what happens when
you're in Oklahoma I think it's actually
either of them and uh
a woman you know you're with a woman she
gets pregnant
and then she decides six months on she
doesn't want to be with you so she flees
to Colorado Colorado no limit on
abortion Oklahoma ban on abortion
so what happens
yeah I I mean I understand why people
are uncomfortable with that thought but
at this point that's the only thing that
I think is going to save pockets of
society so I'm asking you what happens
next she goes to Colorado and gets
abortion and that man says well I guess
she's gonna kill my son and then just
sits there and twiddles his thumbs well
that's the way it is now I mean to be
fair so right right now there is a it
it's that way now that's exactly what
I'm talking about it wasn't that way
before it used to be that there was a
certain like yes these things would
happen yes there are bad stories but the
more people geographically polarize
from each other the more you're and the
more the culture divides and escalates
maybe abortion isn't the issue but you
run into that wall of there's going to
be uh uh a kid kidnapped there's gonna
be a there's gonna be a guy who lives in
a neighborhood
and he's going to have a creepy smile
and he's going to go on Tick Tock and
say kids don't listen to your parents
your parents are bad you should do
whatever you want I support you he's
gonna get a message from a kid who says
actually I live a few blocks away and I
want to get sterilization surgery and
the guy's gonna say I will drive you
personally to California to make this
happen he's going to kidnap the kid go
to California do you think the parents
are going to be like well guess my kid's
sterilized or do you think there's going
to be a conflict between the major
growing cultures between states yeah I
get your point is it the case where a
a third party not related to a child
could take a child yes it is yes wow yep
I think that's specific that might be
specifically in Washington however
that's right Washington State yeah I
think Washington state was the one that
explicitly said anybody who who helps a
child receive gender affirming care will
will not face prosecution in their state
so when we live in a post-rational
society which we do there's no Universal
reason anymore and we live in a
quasi-democracy where the people of the
country get to decide what is right and
wrong basically I mean where is the win
in the end there getting rich
I mean there's no there's no moral win
in the end because you're dealing with
people who don't believe in the same
thing you do so that's why I'm saying at
this point in the game you should move
places where people do agree with you
because it's the only hope you're never
going to convert the country sure I I
don't completely disagree my point is
just that
you have to ask yourself what happens
after everyone
geographically polarizes
I think the liberal cities are going to
continue to fall apart I mean and then
what happens when people in cities don't
have food or water they're gonna leave
or they're gonna die I mean it's gonna
get bad but they're not just going to
leave
what so if you look at like New York
City liberal City most of the states
relatively red so what is the city going
to do when the city is struggling it
doesn't have food or water the same
thing the left always does steal it from
somebody else
the easiest thing to do is to go up go
up North and go to the rural farms and
just seize their food hey it's What
communists do they're going to say the
people need this more than you they
already do it in California with the
water they tell the farmers where the
lifeblood of the whole state and a good
portion of this country that they don't
have surface water rights because the
surface water has to go to the liberal
cities where people have voting power
then the poor people who live in these
in these farming districts lose access
to well water when the farmers drill
into the Earth to get groundwater to to
grow crops you can already see how that
starts to break down my experience in
California during the drought made me
understand the importance of the
Electoral College why it is absolutely
necessary uh and the Senate and and
Congress how the founding fathers did
this it's brilliant in California you
have poor migrant workers
and their Wells their well for the for
water run 30 feet deep
there's Canal water running through this
in Tulare County and I ask the farmers
why don't you use that water there they
said we're not allowed to it's illegal
because the cities voted to take the
water and the politicians say well the
people need water first so what the
Farms do then is they drill tens of
thousands of feet thousands of feet into
the Earth for groundwater which drains
the groundwater and now all the poor
people have no water anymore their
30-foot Wells can't reach water and the
water stops
the Electoral College changes the way
the votes voting system would work now
you can't just go to this small or I
would say a republican system and I mean
that in the in the in the philosophical
sense not in the colloquial sense you
have to go to them and say we need you
all to vote we can't just vote to take
from you
so that's the point when you look at why
we break things down by States why they
have Senators so that you can't just say
we out vote you therefore we get your
water right and my statement is it's not
broken down enough have you heard of the
Free State of Jefferson initiatives and
California trying to break into three
different states right greater Idaho
yeah exactly those are the type of
things that need to happen because
you're right San Francisco and La
control an entire State now and that's
the problem is all that centralized
control so if that can be removed and
dispersed I think that's the only
peaceful solution it's not a peaceful
solution I don't disagree I think it is
a better move to make now
but when you have 10 million people in
the New York Metro and it's it's falling
apart and collapsing decent amount of
them leave and a decent amount of them
will band together and say we deserve it
and then you get conflict you're gonna
have people in cities like the Colorado
River is a really interesting problem
the Great Lakes are a real interesting
problem you've got States I think it was
Arizona trying to sue to uh to claim the
rights over Great Lakes water arguing
the Great Lakes are part of the United
States and the water should be dispersed
and then you're the Great Lakes
Coalition fortunately because I believe
Ontario is a part of it it's now
International and other states can't
just drain the Great Lakes but the Great
Lakes need to be replenished they go
down if if there's too much consumption
I see what I see happening with places
like San Francisco and why I'm concerned
about them is that as they fall into
chaos those people who live there there
they need food and they need water they
need shelter and they want security and
if that falls apart even by their own
fault they will come and take it from
you and that means maybe they just move
to where you live and then start voting
for things that destroy your systems or
maybe they stay there it continues to
Decay and then eventually they just
start going and stealing from farms
passing laws where they lock Farms down
and claim property and you get communism
I mean how is that not happening under
our Federalist system we have now though
the same thing's happening they're doing
that so every single state if we had
property rights if we had a federal
system that actually enforced equality
under the law you have a lot less of
this now someone shows up and says I get
your farm they say I sue you now it goes
to the federal government they supersede
the state and say you can't do that you
can't take someone's Farm but that's
breaking down and that's the issue we
don't have a share like it's a it's a
combination of things it's not just
government its culture we don't have a
shared moral framework anymore you have
the rise of leftists and the funny thing
is the success of this nation gave rise
to weak-minded entitled individuals who
seek to steal from others without doing
any of the work and that leads to
collapse I mean these people vote so
they vote they vote to take and they
keep doing it and then what ends up
happening is one of two things as a
system starts to break down you either
get Revolution or well there's a few
ways reform is really possible but it's
really hard you're either going to get a
revolution or Civil War if it really
does escalate to that point and I kind
of feel like when we learned the doj is
going after Trump's lawyers
that that like look man it was already
unprecedented the doj went after Joe
Biden's political rival Donald Trump
unprecedented
now they're saying they're going to go
after Trump's lawyers the people giving
him legal counsel the government
basically saying if you provide
constitutionally protected services
legal representation to someone who we
oppose we're gonna lock you up there's
there's an obvious next step to this
advocacy they're already saying they
were political Consultants one of the
co-conspirators was a consultant not
even a lawyer someone who advocated that
Trump file uh these lawsuits and and
seek alternate electors the next step is
fairly obvious those who incite criminal
uh criminal actions they've already made
the claim that it's not free speech to
incite criminal activity right so now
when they say that Donald Trump's
actions in 2020 were criminal The Next
Step Beyond his lawyers is anyone who
publicly spoke advocacy for Donald
Trump's illegal actions was inciting
people to commit crimes and they're next
so I think the South should have been
allowed to secede during the Civil War
and the Rewritten history about it is
that it was all about slavery that had
nothing to do with anything else and
that has built an American dream that
it's wrong to let people leave this
country and wrong to let people do their
own thing and that it's morally correct
to bind us all together as one country
if the South had actually left
I don't think you know the north was
kind of doing what you're describing
that leftists do is always trying to
reach out and get more power they were
taxing the South a lot more than they
should have been
um and so that type of thing is
happening now the you know the the
Reconstruction uh mindset has really
just like kept going and given us the
Progressive Era and destroyed this
country and unless we finally just break
off and say you know what we don't know
what we don't all belong under the same
system we need to have you know
different governments that you know
respect people the way they want to live
and you know I just I just think it's
the only way we can go forward and then
what what happens after that
uh I think that
the leftists are always going to want
more control like you said but the only
way to not give it to them is starve
them of it right what likely happens
after a separation if the United States
were to break into two and the left
called it like Jesus land and the United
States of Canada that's the meme they
put out the next likely thing to happen
is a unipolar Chinese Communist planet
where trade is going to be regulated
under their currency and their and their
rules and their whims and you're going
to end up with not NATO control but Brix
control that could go on for several
decades maybe 100 years who knows what
that means for Americans is well for one
it could mean less war it could mean
that we can live peacefully in farm in
our own States and mind our own business
but it means your standard of living
drops by some odd 90 percent and that
and that's you know I'm not saying
that's that's necessarily a bad thing I
mean the issue is the Petro dollar it
props up our economy and makes Americans
wealthy based off nothing when the when
this country splits into the Petro
dollar ceases to exist brics event brics
Nations basically take over the global
economy and oil trade and that means
Americans have to once again start
producing and we don't so for those that
advocate for this the end result is
going to be you will work more than
you've ever worked in your life and your
standard of living will be 90 lower me
personally
I don't mind tending to chickens and
animals and working on a farm and
reading books and just just working
every day
he's liberals and he's leftists they're
gonna cry they're gonna cry more they've
ever cried in their lives and they're
going to beg to bring back the Petro
dollar don't you think that's kind of an
inevitability at this point though like
it's that's why it's avoidable yeah I
mean well I mean look in in the event
that uh uh I really do mean it if you
get a Donald Trump of a vague or even a
Rhonda santis if they win and they
actually do follow through on the things
they've said it's not inevitable
there's act there's there's a there is a
possibility that we come out on top of
this successfully and that's that's
still sort of bad news for anti-war
individuals because the U.S machine just
keeps on keeping on but to fire corrupt
prosecutors to criminally charge corrupt
politicians and to reform and and
restore the actual uh like I don't want
to say uh moral framework of the past in
its entirety but the core moral
Frameworks of Classical liberalism the
founding fathers believed in then things
start to repair and strengthen but
you've got to get rid of the rot you got
to carve out the rot first and then
rebuild there's part of me that does
think that if you can
if you can wake up the average live
right the average liberal that gets
conned into illiberal things because
some authoritarian convinces them that
they'll be safer or they'll be looked at
you know as the nice guy or it's you
know it's racist to not do this or
whatever the the con from the the
progressives is if you can convince your
average bad liberal that they're being a
bad liberal and they need to come back
to things like the rule of law the
freedom of speech that that things like
the rule of law has a big effect on you
know the crew the criminal element in
your cities and and that has a big
effect on the economy and if you can if
you can remind liberals that these
things actually do matter and that
they're the way they've been voting and
and the behaviors of the politicians
they're electing are actually illiberal
then I think that you could have a pause
positive result without some kind of
massive Revolution but without the
people realizing that the things that
they're asking the government to do are
bad illiberal and producing the results
that they actually don't like as long as
people don't realize that as long as
they think that voting for The then what
sounds nice is the is the proper course
of action there's not going to be any
significant change I just wanted to also
add that you know not just on a Warfare
front but on an economic front ever
since we've been on the Petro dollar the
dollar has lost you know all its value
if you look 1971 we came off the gold
standard standard and then I think in
1974 we went on the Petro dollar and
ever since then the dollar has just
tanked so I don't think it was a I don't
think it was a reliable system even with
you know competent leadership I don't
think it was sustainable I want to show
you this picture this is the only path
forward right here everyone take a look
that's it who does I'm just kidding this
is this is so I pulled up some AI images
that I made because I think they're
funny but uh look at this guy's hat like
this one guy over here is wearing a very
very tiny hat for some reason this is a
mid-journey made this it's uh
generalissimo Trump but uh I want to
show you another image
this is uh what the establishment fears
Donald Trump shaking hands with Sonic
the Hedgehog but uh this one is actually
the one I I want you to see because
if if you were to actually if you remove
Sonic the Hedgehog from this image it
actually looks like a real photo of
Donald Trump running down the street
there's the the average person's not
gonna be able to understand that this
was generated by AI
granted we put Sonic the Hedgehog in it
so we know this is not real this is what
I'm talking about with the with the
political battle that's that's coming on
uh coming up
this next year the Deep fakes that we
are going to see of audio a video it's
it's No One's Gonna know it's real there
is not I mean look if Joe Biden is
willing to steal the private
Communications of trump and try and lock
him up you think Democrats aren't going
to make fake audio of them fake videos
of him you're gonna do all that and more
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time